Hi, Michael.
>> Hey Charles, well that was fun.
>> That was fun, we should do it again.
>> I don't think we need to do it again.
I think we've now covered
everything we wanted to say about
reinforcement learning.
>> And
I'm completely sure that we haven't.
>> Well, what haven't we covered?
>> Well,
what haven't we haven't we covered?
>> Well, we haven't,
we haven't we covered TD-Lambda.
>> Sure.
So, we talked about TD lambda.
We talked about a few algorithms here or
there, but we haven't really
touched on the big questions.
We haven't covered
everything that we should.
>> Like?
>> BURLAP!
>> We have definitely covered BURLAP.
>> Okay, sure, there was a tutorial, and
there were assignments about it, but
you haven't answered the big
question about BURLAP.
Which is what?
>> Why BURLAP?
Why do we need anything like BURLAP?
Why don't you just use the UCI
database and Weka we're done.
>> Right so the UCI data set their
depository and Weka are really great for
supervised learning but
they're not actually well situated for
reinforcement learning.
Weka doesn't include reinforcement
learning algorithms it
the UCI repository doesn't include
reinforcement learning problems in it.
You really need a different set up for
dealing with reinforcement
learning problems.
>> You need a different, okay,
I don't understand that.
So we have algorithms, we've talked
about many of them in class.
>> That's right.
>> So algorithms, are algorithms,
are algorithms, are algorithms, and
this is all machine learning and
so all we need is data.
And that's what repositories are for,
data.
So, well yes, BURLAP is trying
to answer both of those issues.
One of the things that
BURLAP is trying to be is
a collection of those algorithms or
algorithms or
algorithms or algorithms and it's also
providing a replacement for data.
So data in the reinforcement learning
setting is really hard to work with.
Instead, what BURLAP has
is a set of simulators,
the ability to Act
like the environment so
that the learning algorithm can
interact with it and learn from them.
[CROSSTALK] I see so the keyword there
is in Iraq, so the notion of supervised
learning as you just got data you got
him put it up with pairs input and
output pairs, but as we pointed out
multiple times reinforcement learning
is not just about input output you and
back Get to see states and
rewards you take actions.
Those are the kinds of thing that you
do and that requires interaction.
>> Right and the data that you actually
see depends on how you're exploring
the environment so just capturing a big
static set of data and presenting that
to the learner isn't really
the reinforcement learning process.
>> Okay, so I like that.
So I heard two things there.
One thing I like, and
one thing I don't like.
The thing that I like is that you
distinguished reinforcement learning
from supervised learning.
You talked about the need for
interaction and
how that's sort of crucial, and you said
your solution was having simulators.
>> Right, so,
I agree that that's not a great thing.
So simulators are good in the sense that
you can actually interact with them,
and so it's a way of transferring and
an environment or
a test problem from one research
group to another research Group.
[CROSSTALK] Sounds good.
But on the bad side
they're not really data,
it's not actual data
coming from a problem.
It's just fit.
[CROSSTALK] So then you're suggesting
this is the second thing that I didn't
thing I like you're suggesting that we
don't have any way to make reinforcement
learning work in the real world.
It is more challenging, but it is not
the case that reinforcement learning
hasn't been used to solve
some real problems.
>> Like what?
>> So, it's worth probably
mentioning a few of them.
We talked about backgammon
as part of the class,
the TD-Gammon algorithm that actually
learn to play backgammon at a level
comparable to,
if not better than, human beings.
There's other sorts of problems that are
probably worth talking about as well.
Elevator control is an interesting
problem to think about.
>From a reinforcement
learning perspective.
>> How so?
How is an elevator controller
reinforcement learning about?
>> Elevator control if you think about
the elevators in a building they're
trying to work together to move
people to where they want to go.
And so we have actions,
we have states and we have rewards.
The actions are where the elevators
are trying to go, whether or
not they're going to open
their doors at a given floor.
The states are what
is the arrangement of
all the different
elevators at the moment.
Which floors have elevators on them,
which don't.
>> Which buttons have been pressed.
So who's waiting on which floors.
And from the reward perspective
you can try to get the system to try to
minimize wait time for people, right?
So that's something
that you can measure,
how long is somebody waiting on the
third floor for the elevator to come,
and then eventually getting
to the destination floor and
that's something you can measure and
something that you can try to
find ways of behaving to improve.
Okay cool, so
that's a reinforcement learning problem.
I like that, anything else?
>> Yeah, so that one actually
was done in simulation.
>> Okay.
>> But there has been some good work
in reinforcement learning in robotics.
So one that's maybe worth mentioning
is the the helicopter work.